this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Squarespace we sure do have
fun here at fun science don't we kids
however today it's time for the fun to
end
don't worry fun science will return
please stay subscribed but it is time
for us to get serious as today we're
going to be tackling one of the most
important topics of all time
cuddles yeah hang on there charlie
what's so serious about cuddles well
what if I told you then not only can a
good hug make you feel good but can also
reduce your chances of getting sick
increase your likelihood that your team
will win at sports and the cuddles can
directly impact how much babies grow
before we get into that stuff however
let's talk about the power of touch
whenever you use your sense of touch all
the information is sent to two different
systems inside your brain the
somatosensory cortex which deals with
the facts of where and how you've been
touched and posterior insula which
handles the emotions associated with the
touch let's see them in action
oh I've just been punched in the
shoulder I'm experiencing pain
I am being lightly stroked on my
shoulder so while in they feel sometimes
like sensations of touch are giving you
an accurate representation of the world
around you so long as your posterior
insula is functioning correctly you
don't feel without also experiencing in
motion however being hit with the fields
as it were isn't the only way that your
brain affects touch have you ever tried
tickling yourself not that easy is it
well that's because our brains are
hard-wired to ignore sensations of touch
that originate from our own motion
however when we receive those same
sensations from the outside world this
makes sense as from an evolutionary
standpoint there's no real benefit to
being spooked by your own hand whereas
if say a venomous insect were to crawl
up your body a quick response could be
the difference between life you've got
something new or something it's right
here it's right here to get it anyway
now that I've given you a basic idea of
how touch works what about some of its
powers well did you know that something
as small as receiving a gentle touch
from a server makes you more likely to
give them a higher tip for the
basketball players who touch each other
regularly by hugging high-fiving and the
like tend to perform better on the court
in fact it's even been found that
patients who receive say a reassuring
touch on the shoulder from their doctor
tend to have better medical outcomes to
explain why this might work let's focus
finally on cuts during a good hug your
brain releases a chemical called
oxytocin you might have heard it
referred to as the love hormone as it
plays a role in bonding between romantic
partners and between parents and
children but it can also help facilitate
social bonding like this however while
oxytocin does have some downsides it can
do much more than simply bring people
together after asking for hundred
healthy adults about the number of hugs
they typically received over two weeks
researchers at Carnegie Mellon
University found the people who received
more hug
are somewhat more protected from
infection than those who received fewer
hoaxes so what could be happening here
well one of the effects of the release
of oxytocin is that it protects against
stress and when you have lower stress
your immune system functions better
which leaves you more equipped to fight
against infectious diseases however the
positive effect that cuddles can have on
infants might be their greatest power of
all perhaps you've heard of Harlow's
monkey experiments where infant rhesus
monkeys were given a choice between a
mother made of wire with a food source
and another made of cloth with no food
source overwhelmingly the monkeys choose
to spend their time with the cloth
mother and cuddled with them for hours
on end while an experiment like that
would now be considered unethical it
does show us that infants instinctively
know the value of cuddles it was a good
thing they do too as if babies
experienced our lack of them known as
touch deprivation not only can their
growth be stunted but it can also
adversely affect their behavior all the
way into adulthood
clearly the hug is very special indeed
and the countries like the US and UK
where there seems to be a cultural fear
of hugging it's particularly important
that we open our arms for good hug
whenever we can uh-oh sounds like
someone out there is in need of some
consensual comforting cuddles this seems
like a job for and until we see each
other again
always remember cuddles are serious
business
[Music]
see now I'm wondering if those people
who walk around with those free hug
signs are clearly missing a trick
you know hugs could be a powerful
commodity what about 5 pounds for a
deluxe hug or 20 pounds for a platonic
spooning session regardless if you have
your own business idea who flip one
better than mine Squarespace is a great
place to set up shop many of their
templates are specifically designed to
help you sell your stuff if you're
interested to start your free trial
today and go to Squarespace com4 slash
fun science to get 10% off your first
purchase although no promises that
they'll actually let you sell hugs
online also this is the last episode of
fun science in this run but if you'd
like to support the show so we can make
more episodes like this in the future
consider becoming a patron just go to
patreon.com/scishow and take a look for
yourself thanks a lot everyone see you
soon
bye